[Music]
love holidays is one of the UK's largest
online travel agencies and is also one
of the country's fastest growing
businesses with growth came the need to
provide an amazing customer experience
at scale
love holidays sought to share
personalized and relevant information
with each customer based on a deeper
understanding of what their customers
were actually looking for all while
making the exchange of this information
intuitive and efficient that's why love
holidays turn to Google Cloud contact
center AI so let's dive into how they
made this happen with Tom Smith
telecommunications operations manager at
love holidays when building our virtual
assistant Sandy
we started by very simply greeting our
customers and asking why they were
contacting us
our primary goal has always been to
create a seamless and efficient
experience
helping our customers to get the
information they require as quickly and
easily as possible rather than to
attempt to deliberately deflect or
contain
initially we listened to what our
customers asked for and pass them
straight through to our customer service
team this approach allowed us to quickly
gather a lot of information around the
needs of our customers and we were able
to start grouping and categorizing
different customer intents was the
customer looking for a specific piece of
information about their holidays like
how to check in
or did they want to make an amendment to
their booking
we took these intents and started to
build them into dialogflow
using the various different ways in
which customers would phrase questions
to train the virtual agent
once the intents were defined we created
intent routes to handle customer queries
by matching their intents ensuring the
virtual agent would identify the purpose
behind each interaction and provide
relevant answers
we crafted responses that were
informative and intentionally broad
ensuring that as many customers as
possible received accurate information
we extensively utilized the simulator
within dialogflow to test various
scenarios and outcomes before deploying
to the customer facing environment
we continuously monitored and evaluated
conversations iterating Sandy's language
and tone to better suit our customers
preferences we invested in increasing
Sandy's knowledge to cover a larger
range of intents and as Sandy grew we
dedicated significant time to improving
the customer experience using web hooks
to pull an individual's booking data so
that we could provide a highly
personalized service addressing the
customer by name including details
around their destination and travel
dates
we are able to talk to the customer
about the specifics of their holiday
establish a personal connection and
deliver accurate answers that instill
confidence
this heightened level of personalization
had an impressive impact leading to an
increase in the number of conversations
that customers engaged in solely with
Sandy without requiring human
intervention
as we continue to invest in dialogflow
and enhance Sandy's capabilities we
anticipate this number to continue to
rise solidifying Sandy's role as an
invaluable automated resource for our
customers and our business
building Sandy with contact center AI
help love holidays handle a two thousand
five hundred percent increase in demand
during the recent pandemic resolving
over 500 000 cases in just a year by
building up Sandy love holidays now is
able to automate service in 55 of their
customer conversations accomplishing
work equivalent to 120 agents per day
and saving love holidays over 3 million
pounds in just a year
to learn how you can integrate contact
center AI into your customer experience
check out the links in the description
below
foreign
[Music]